now it is quite common to hear people
progressives in particular say that sex
actually doesn't have any intrinsic
value to it it doesn't have any
intrinsic specialness like if people
want to apply meaning to it on a
personal level they're welcome to but
when it comes down to it it's just a
social interaction you know you can buy
it you can sell it it's fine I don't
think anyone really believes that I
think almost no one actually believes
that and you can tell because people are
extraordinarily inconsistent in applying
this so people who for instance will say
that sex work is work no problem it's
just like working McDonald's will not
apply that to their own personal lives
or not even apply it to other sort of
similar issues in terms of Law and
policy so the example I give in the book
is sex for rent all of the major
political parties in the UK are united
in believing that landlords who offer
rooms in exchange for sexual favors are
or should be breaking the law these are
exactly the same parties like the
libdems for instance condemn sex for
rent and think we should decriminalize
the sex industry it's the same thing